the Joe Rogan experience do you do you
remember on MTV they had a show called
true true life and there's a guy that
got calf implants do you remember that
by chance I remember I remember that
remember that from True Life and I was
like what a [ __ ] like didn't you
always like have someone who's never had
all those muscles
I would always seek like those guys and
be like I'd rather not have it then do
what this bird like oh I saw that as
such a pathetic thing to do have a
foreign body yeah sticking inside of you
this the grew a problem with that it's
the same thing that happens to some
women when they get breast implants yes
answer girls are getting that in their
ass now yeah there's there's new
instances of ass cancer that are
directly caused by these ass implants
the ass implants I mean that is
obviously probably the more important
statistic that I think that I don't
think they look good get ass cancer AZ
imagine to get ass cancer because you're
too lazy to do squats so don't you find
that like a it is like this but if you
don't you find it like almost more
permissible forgivable in a way to say
like this woman's getting breast
implants you go like okay yeah but like
if a guy's like oh I got PEC implants
yeah [ __ ] push dude I know a dude who
had PEC implants here hit a bunch of
stuff done I know I know what I did when
I saw him what something that I never do
we pat him on the chest and I didn't
know he had it surgery that day and I
was like good to see he was like and
that's the only reason he no one wants
to confess that I think guy that I know
killed himself
oh really yeah he was getting a bunch of
plastic surgery I'm just killing himself
this guy should really up tommy-gun oh
my god dude it's gross what Tommy
Morrison went off the deep end like this
after he died he pot hearing
hiv-positive he's doing all kinds of
crazy drugs and he got PEC implants and
they were preposterous Jamie I know
you're on this look at that look at that
oh that's him after we want to fight HIV
positive with PEC implants that looks
horrible
this is even worse pictures but look at
the picture of him when he didn't have
him right there right no I'm probably
talking plants yeah those are PEC
implants that's when he didn't have him
that's when he fought George Foreman he
was [ __ ] jacked when he was young I
mean he looked fantastic
he'd punch dirt for me yeah win that
fight No um yes he did he beat George
Foreman Merkin people he wanted decision
from over George Foreman which is a
substantial victory he's like he's like
the chicken of boxing well comic ya know
he beat some good guys a brother yes he
did he beat razor ruddock he stopped him
dropped him with a big left hook Tom
Martin had a nasty left hook he just
couldn't win the big fight and he got
destroyed by Ray Mercer after rocky look
at that picture him after you got
arrested see that picture right right
next to your cursor above that above
that chain right there
that's that's him on the right hand side
HIV+ all [ __ ] up oh yeah did he ever
get it he looked like he was a dog I
think he died of AIDS but that was oh my
god he was falling apart his life was
over I mean he was just 44 yeah yeah he
died real young Wow
and that was him at 44 he looks like a
seven year old man he died at 44 yeah
yeah he was not doing good man and he
got addicted to all kinds of drugs and
was just you know his health fell apart
it was not good I wish someone would do
a documentary on chicken
he got I mean Tommy Morrison got famous
for he was a good boxer like a really
good boxer and then he got famous from
that Rocky movie and then his whole life
fell apart he was so good in that movie
yeah we were high school and that movie
was out and we were standing up in the
aisles like going come on rock it was a
good [ __ ] movie was a good good box
it was good actor there's always a thing
though right of like if a white boxer is
decent great white hope kind of factors
Russians yes he vadacurry Klitschko held
the title forever and no one give a [ __ ]
right he's not American well they're an
American and also they had a kind of a
boring style but that's him in the movie
but in real life he was a very good
boxer up until the time that he did that
Rahman but I think was I think [ __ ] was
just like they were putting [ __ ] in
slingshots and just [ __ ]
yeah I mean he was a handsome guy he was
a movie star and people thought that he
was gonna be the next heavyweight
champion the world and did you ever see
the Ray Mercer fight Oh cue that up
because it's one of the most brutal
knockouts just queue up Ray Mercer Kos
Tommy Morrison well it is [ __ ]
horrible I mean is one of the worst
because he gets tangled in the ropes if
you said no I was watching with my
friend Kevin we were at a bar and we
were watching it and just go to the part
where he gets ko to the end it's [ __ ]
rough man he gets a lot sits he gets
before that before that way before that
he gets yeah so he gets yeah there it is
before just go right go this so Ray
Mercer he started getting tired and Ray
Mercer catches him in the corner and he
unloads on him and Tommy Morrison's arms
get tangled in the ropes we can't go
down like look at this see he's tangled
in the row [ __ ] bro I mean it was one of
the worst Kos I ever remember seeing
look at that I mean Ray Mercer was a
murderer he was an Olympic gold medalist
to have late stop the referee was scared
to get in there and bring Mercer was
back then like no-one's cheering brush
is the one who fought that white M Omega
yeah Tim Sylvia I owed him with one
punch and that was a rough one too
because they were supposed to have a
boxing match and Tim Sylvia kicked his
leg yeah they both agreed those MMA but
we're not gonna kick this is why the
Commission wouldn't allow it to be a
boxing match because Ray Mercer was a
world champion Olympic gold medals and
Tim Sylvia did not have an MMA fight or
did not have a boxing fight but he was
you know a very high level and then a
fighter so they just but he was past his
prime so they decided to have they
called it an MMA fight Ray Mercer was I
think a general agreement
I think Ray Mercer was 46 at a time he
sees a gentleman's agreement look at his
face like come on man you just said
something like that
watch him setting this up bein and then
it gets on top of it goes this whole
fight takes a few seconds look at this
that is a hammer of a punch that's a
slow fall and you know it was already
way past Tim Sylvia's Prime
tim sylvia when he was young it was a
[ __ ] animal he was one that led his
army of broken yes I'm a woman fighting
I want to get Frank Mir broke his arm
everyone was fighting you want to and it
was one you could just kind of move up
until people like sat in the front you
were just in love just sit there you
know like a baseball game and then uh
Tim silver was there and Tate was there
with me and he said hi to him and he was
wearing his belt and it made my first
ever fight and he would he had a
championship belt and I was like later
today toes like are they supposed to
like wear their belts out and he goes no
he just does that tim sylvia wore them
every store just wears his belt as his
belt hey he look man when you're the
heavyweight champ of the world you can
do whatever the [ __ ] you want you want
to bring that thing everywhere good
bring it everyone
[Applause]